I'm an Australian and I'm an artist.
I'm a composer.
I've lived in the UK for the last four years.
I came here to do a job.
I'm the Director of the Edinburgh International Festival.
There seems to be a common perception,...
...let's not beat around the bush, that the UK is up-itself.
I'm here to tell you that nothing could be further from the truth.
This is an incredibly diverse, incredibly welcoming meritocracy.
Edinburgh in August is, I think, a great example of what the UK can do...
...and do very well: let its hair down.
The Edinburgh Festival was started to offer people hope...
...at a time that had been seen to be so hopeless after the Second World War.
In 1947, the Edinburgh Festival started when the landscape in Europe was horrific.
There was no town, no part of Europe that had been unscathed by the bombing.
It couldn't be held in Coventry, it couldn't be held in Manchester,...
...it couldn't be held in Birmingham or London because the places were bombed to blazes.
Edinburgh stages Scotland's first international music and drama festival.
I think one of the reasons it was so successful...
...was that not only did people open their minds...
...and receive really interesting culture from places they'd hardly ever heard of, let alone been to.
2,000 artists taking part in a total of 174 performances.
But most important of all, they opened their hearts.
And there was the most extraordinary sense that we should share what we have.
We should share our food, we should share our shelter.
But perhaps most important of all, we should share our culture.